ya estamos en la recta final ya solo nos
resta calcular esta tercera integral que
está definida sobre esta parte superior
de nuestro pequeño cilindro digamos
rebanado así que vamos a pensar en una
parametrización y para eso déjenme
copiar y pegar esta superficie para
llevarla allá abajo
copiamos y pegamos de este lado
y pegamos ok muy bien y ya tenemos
nuevamente nuestra superficie y déjenme
regresar a los colores muy bien entonces
realmente lo que queremos calcular es la
integral de z de s sobre s 3 muy bien
entonces aquí además sabemos que esta
superficie no es otra cosa más que a
este círculo unitario lo elevamos hasta
dónde está el plano verdad es decir es
es una función que va del de este
círculo hacia hacia este plano entonces
realmente está definido por el plano 7
igual a 1 - x en donde ahora nosotros
tenemos que determinar quién es esta
región para saber cuál es la región acá
arriba del plano que realmente nos
estamos tomando entonces para hacer eso
vamos a parametrizar la circunferencia
unitaria o el círculo unitario de acá
adentro y eso es muy sencillo porque ya
lo hay mucho ya lo hemos hecho varias
veces
tratar de pintar mis mis ejes
en mis dos ejes este es el eje digamos
el eje y y este es el eje x y lo que
vamos a tener aquí es digamos la
proyección de esta etapa de esta etapa
del cilindro sobre el plano entonces nos
da esta circunstancia roja que déjenme
tratar de pintarla lo más agradable
posible
ok más o menos
esta es la idea sale este es mi círculo
unitario y para parametrizar lo pues
primero necesitamos saber qué tanto nos
estamos moviendo alrededor del centro en
qué ángulo justamente así vamos a
definir este primer parámetro que va a
ser el ángulo
y para llamarle ángulo pues déjenme usar
teta que no vemos que no habíamos
utilizado ya esa esa letra y este ángulo
pues lo que nos permite decirnos
moviendo en digamos recorriendo lo de
forma circular estos puntos verdad
cuando theta es cero empieza aquí y a
medida que vamos aumentando theta vamos
moviéndonos en esta dirección la otra el
otro detalle es que tenemos que rellenar
esta circunferencia entonces no sólo eso
sino que además necesitamos definir aquí
otro parámetro digamos
esto que nos diga qué tan a qué tanta
distancia nos estamos moviendo del
centro y ese vamos a llamarle r muy bien
entonces tenemos dos parámetros esto no
es otra cosa más que las coordenadas
polares así que en nuestro primer
parámetro r
sólo se puede mover entre 0 y 1 porque
es la distancia a la que podemos estar
del centro hasta el círculo más grande
que es de radio 1 entonces tenemos que 0
menor o igual que erre que es menor o
igual que uno y la otra es que que tanto
nos movemos que tanto damos vuelta esa
es la forma de verlo y eso nos dice que
el ángulo puede estar entre 0 y 2 pi ok
entonces aquí está ya definido a la
región de los parámetros sólo hay que
definir bien la parametrización y una de
ellas es x en sus coordenadas polares
que es r coseno de teta ye igual a r
seno de teta iceta pero zeta ceta no es
otra cosa más que 1 - x y x r coseno
beteta entonces esto es 1 - r coseno dt
está ok entonces pues todavía podemos
dar incluso nuestra nuestra
parametrización en términos de una
función vectorial de dos parámetros como
digamos pues si si el punto de la
superficie 3 que depende de r
lo escribimos de esta forma pues en su
primera coordenada en su primera
coordenada lo podemos expresar como r
coseno de teta por y más la segunda
coordinada es el seno de teta que esto
va en la dirección del vector jota más
en la tercera coordenada es 1 - r coseno
de teta que multiplica al vector k muy
bien entonces esta es nuestra función
vectorial y ahora para calcular d es lo
que tenemos que hacer es déjenme ver
donde lo teníamos de ese es el producto
cruz de nuestras derivadas de la
parametrización bueno aquí no estamos
usando ni ere ni un nivel pero pero lo
que estamos haciendo lo que vamos a
hacer es el producto cruz de las de las
derivadas de s
respecto de r&d respecto de teta después
obtenemos su magnitud o su norma y ya ya
podremos ir calculando a bs entonces
empecemos con ese producto cruz que no
es otra cosa más que un determinante
un determinante
yo creo que sí va a necesitar todo este
espacio
fue un poco chueco
ahí está entonces vamos a calcular un
determinante donde aquí ponemos el
vector y el vector jota y el vector k
luego en el siguiente renglón vamos a
poner en azul la derivada de ese 3
respecto de ere y si derivamos la
primera coordenada respecto de r nos
queda coseno coseno detecta están de
acuerdo luego si derivamos la segunda
coordenada respecto de r nos queda seno
de teta y si derivamos la última
respecto de r pues simplemente esto es
una constante y nos queda menos coseno
de teta - coseno de teta porque lo demás
son constantes para fines de derivar
respecto de r en el último renglón vamos
a hacer la derivada de esto respecto de
teta entonces si derivamos ere coseno
ett al respecto de teta vamos a tener
que la derivada de co seno de teta es
menos seno de teta entonces aquí
tendremos menos r
seno de teta luego la derivada de rs no
detecta es r jose no detecta y la
derivada de esto último pues simplemente
el 1 es una constante se anula al
derivar y nos queda menos r por la
derivada de coseno de teta que es menos
seno de teta entonces los menos se
cancelan y simplemente nos queda r seno
de teta este es el determinante que hay
que calcular entonces
de hecho déjenme irme un poquito más
abajo
esto va a ser simplemente podemos
escribir s 3 s s
s 3 cuando derivamos respecto de r cruz
s 3 cuando derivamos respecto de teta
pues va a ser si nos tomamos nuestra
coordenada i
nuestra nuestra primera entrada y
quitamos columna y renglón nos queda
este pequeño determinante verdad seno de
teta por r seno dt taques rs no cuadrado
de teta menos el producto de estos dos
que es r coseno beteta por coseno de
teta con el menos se cancelan entonces
simplemente nos queda el seno cuadrado
de teta más r coseno cuadrado de teta
que multiplica nuestro vector y ok menos
aquí va el menos porque ya estamos
saltando a esta segunda entrada quitamos
columna y quitando renglón y nos queda
coseno por 13-9 teta es r
se no detecta coseno de teta y menos el
producto de estos dos que el producto de
estos dos se anulan los signos y nos
queda
rc no detecta coseno beteta menos rs no
detecta coseno detecta por jota y ahora
as
tenemos que sumar el lo correspondiente
al vector k entonces si quitamos renglón
y columna nos queda r coseno cuadrado de
teta menos el producto de estos dos pero
con este menos se va y nos queda r
más sería más r seno cuadrado de teta
que multiplica al vector k lo único que
nos resta es calcular la norma verdad
porque si nos damos cuenta estos se
cancelan esto se hace 0 son exactamente
los mismos términos y ahora también
podemos ver de aquí que si factor izamos
una erre nos queda
r por seno cuadrado de teta más coseno
cuadrado de teta que esto es 1 entonces
aquí sólo nos queda r y pasa exactamente
lo mismo en esta tercera coordenada o
sea esto es r y + 0 digamos j + r acá
por lo tanto quien es la norma la norma
de este de esto de este vector la norma
de este vector entonces nos va a quedar
que la norma del mismo s 3r cruz s 3
zeta
va a ser la raíz cuadrada de quien de r
al cuadrado más 0 al cuadrado más r al
cuadrado que es r cuadrada más r
cuadrada que no es otra cosa más que dos
veces r cuadrada que si sacamos raíz a
cada uno de ellos nos queda la raíz de
dos por r muy bien ya nada más nos queda
entonces si ésta es la norma del
producto cruz ya podemos ir calculando
quién es la integral de zeta de s
a lo largo o sobre esta superficie s 3
porque esto va a ser igual a la raíz de
bueno
aquí podemos poner esta raíz de 2 hasta
afuera esto es la raíz de 2 verdad de la
integral vamos a integrar primero
respecto que les parece bueno esta
integral de afuera que sea respecto de
teta entonces va de 0 a 2 p
de la integral de la integral
con rosa de la integral de 0 a 1 que es
en donde se mueve el radio de quién de z
que es 11 - r coseno de teta ok es tz
por el ds ds es este producto por el
raíz de 2 ya lo pusimos afuera
simplemente nos falta poner r
luego integramos primero respecto a r y
luego vamos a integrar respecto de no
ponerlo así respecto de teta realmente
no importa el orden en el que integremos
ya sea teta o r porque tenemos muy bien
definidos los valores en los cuales se
mueven estos estos dos parámetros no
importa el orden no de hecho ni siquiera
creo que cambie la la complejidad del
problema pero bueno si ya me acabo de
dar cuenta de que ya se me está acabando
el tiempo así que terminaré en el
siguiente vídeo de calcular esta
superficie